okay why don't we why don't we go ahead
and get started want to welcome everyone
actually to the inaugural well to the
kickoff meeting for our research
conference for this academic year and
our speaker is dr. art papier who
someone I've known a long time and it's
been interesting for me to see his his
ideas and his company develop this X is
not the first time he's been here he
spoke in this room probably about 10 or
so years ago and whenever it's mostly
the dermatology folks that that get him
out here he's a dermatologist as I'll
explain in a moment
so there's actually a big dermatology
conference tomorrow one of the topics on
it is diagnostic errors which are not
uncommon in xa in all aspects of
medicine and he'll be talking about that
that tomorrow afternoon you can find out
more about that it's the it's the France
tours lecture and it's on the
dermatology department website but when
our told me he was coming I said you got
to spend an extra day and spend time
with our department which is what he did
when he was here last time so uh dr.
papay is a physician trained practicing
dermatologist developed an interest in
point-of-care tools clinical decision
support and has developed this system
visual DX which is not only on those
computers but also on my phone not that
I try to make any diagnoses with it and
he's in addition to being the founder of
his company which he'll tell us a little
bit about he's also on the faculty at
the University of Rochester Medical
Center in New York and so I explained to
him that there's a wide variety of back
and interests here there are those of
you studying bioinformatics clinical
informatics some of you are physicians
some of you are PhD students or postdocs
so it's it's a real mix and it's
actually good good to see that so anyway
some I will turn over to him and or one
other thing the the the kind of formal
presentation part will go for an hour
and then he's agreed to stay on another
hour in a more informal presentation we
we geared it it's billed as a student
event but anyone is welcome so after
about an hour when he finishes the talk
we'll take a short break and let those
who need to go other places leave and
then he'll be happy to answer your
questions what it's like to to start a
biomedical informatics company and so
forth so I will turn it over to him well
bill thank you so much and it's a
pleasure to be here and let me just
start with my disclosure the CEO I'm a
shareholder of this company and what I
want to do with this talk is begin by
framing up problems and kind of give an
overview and then kind of narrow down
towards diagnostic decision support but
I think you need to be really clear
about this idea of what is decision
support and so this is from Chuck
Friedman who made this graphic where
he's basically we're saying the brain
plus the computer is more powerful than
the brain alone and I have machine
learning AI of any kind rule-based
systems any type of technology I'm
putting in that bucket of computer and
so it's the media likes the frame this
is man versus machine you know we're
going to replace the doctors with
computers soon it's really kind of sexy
for the news media but really most
people believe that we're talking not
about artificial intelligence we're
talking about augmented human
intelligence like having tools for
people and this is really the story of
my professional career I went to med
school in the 80s and when I was in med
school
there were no computers being used and
there obviously no smart phones we had
the stuff called film the young people
in the room don't remember that but it
was really different and it's not that
long ago but we really memory oriented
and had unaided decisions the most you
had maybe was this thing called the
Washington manual shoved in your white
coat and he had scraps of note cards
with calculations and formulas and when
you went on rounds that astute professor
wearing that white coat had miracles of
knowledge that they would try to impart
on you and model for you that you needed
to be fireback answers so the idea was
that you would have answers for the
professor and you certainly would hide
your doubt from patients where I think
we're moving now to be more
process-oriented
have assisted decisions certainly
although students and residents have
smartphones and they have apps that have
calculators in it they had you know this
started really with the Palm Pilot how
many people remember the Palm Pilot so
Epocrates was that first drug checking
app and that really to me it was like
the birth of doctors using point-of-care
computer tools widely it was Epocrates
and then since then you know we've moved
to these great smartphones with lots of
apps that Doc's are using and when we're
in clinic when I'm with my residents I
try to model for them information
acquisition so as an example I had a
resident say to me six months ago we
have a patient room three that I believe
has vasculitis and I said to the
resident well why do you say that she as
well as palpable purpura which is a sign
of vasculitis on the exam I say great
okay well what's the cause of the
vasculitis and she said she didn't know
and I said well let's go through
pathophysiology of vasculitis let's do
categories as an infectious is it
collagen vascular disease related is it
medication related by the way what meds
is a patient on now she wasn't really
sure I said well you really shouldn't
present until you really know that
medalists and when meds were started and
stopped and which
meds potentially could cause vasculitis
good you were saying to me you believe
the patient has vascular vasculitis well
why you should look it up don't present
to me and Julie you check those meds in
a database I don't care if you check it
in a book or in a computer but you need
to look it up and use data to inform
that decision and that's very very
different than just operating out of
your brain when I was in med school
where the professor would just say from
their brain and it wasn't any looking up
so modeling information acquisition I
think is a really important part of
teaching now and then of course shared
decision-making we don't have the kind
of paternalism that we had in medicine
40 50 years ago where doctors are always
knew best so at our company we're really
thinking about this problem of
diagnostic error so there was a report
in 2015 by the Institute of Medicine now
called the National Academy of Medicine
Institute of Medicine that had this
quote that nearly every person will
experience a diagnostic error in their
lifetime so that means all of us me
included all of us in this room will
probably go to a clinician and have a
diagnostic error happen and we created
this infographic to kind of highlight
that this is a problem that's really
been under the waterline in medicine so
a bill remember is like the early days
of decision support we were really
talking about diagnostic tools 40 years
ago or whatever 30 years ago we really
weren't talking about some of the new
definitions of clinical decision support
people were focused on diagnosis
particularly an internal medicine a
while back but over the last 20 years
the quality and safety movement has
really focused on things like wrong site
surgery hospital infections dosing
errors so medication and surgical errors
are newsworthy like when the wrong limb
comes off it hits the newspapers right
away or a dose like Dennis Quaid's the
actor Dennis
newborn twins were given the wrong dose
of heparin and almost died that's in the
news so the public really thinks that's
happening a lot but really the mass of
the iceberg is seventy four thousand
deaths a year tributed two diagnostic
error and a little plug for a meeting if
anyone gets interested in this there's a
meeting called the diagnostic errors in
medicine meeting that's this year will
be November 4th to 8th I think in New
Orleans if you get interest in this
field it's a meeting of researchers and
educators and positions of all
specialties so this is this is the area
that we're really focused on we created
this infographic from it a malpractice
liability company report where you see
diagnostic errors are higher than
surgical errors or medical management
lawsuits or medication lawsuits so that
the all the liability data points to the
diagnostic errors are significant
problem and in this National Academy of
Science report there were eight
recommendations and this was goal three
ensure that health and health
information technology support patients
and healthcare professionals in the
diagnostic process and that's just some
more liability data where diagnostic
related harm outpaces all the others so
in terms of thinking about this health
care system I'm kind of curious for the
clinicians in the room that adhere to
OHSU is there any planning going on to
improve diagnostic accuracy that you've
heard of like in Eminem context it
really is probably it's on the radar
here at all a little bit you think
speak up again yeah yeah I mean s yeah
sure
but the broad broadly what we when I go
around and I give talks like this
usually very few hands go off that it's
really not on this center stage of
quality and safety at most institutions
so another problem in related to
diagnostic errors this is prom of
clinical variability so you know
clinical decision-making and diagnostic
variability there variability is really
hasn't been this focus and how we drive
high reliability into decisions in the
healthcare system and we believe that we
need to start to develop Universal
information platforms that can really
start to reduce all that variability
okay so how did doctors do their
thinking and let me ask how many have
read this book okay so this is a great
book and if you go to the talk tomorrow
I'm sure we'll be referenced by the
other speakers there Daniel Kahneman's a
behavioral economic economist that won a
Nobel Prize and he wrote this wonderful
book explaining system 1 and system 2
thinking and so basically there we go
and let me pause and ask if how many
people read this link look like Malcolm
Gladwell so this is an explanation of
system 1 so let me explain system 1 you
can't keep the answer out of your brain
it was instantaneous when you saw this
and you can't keep what this structure
is out of your brain its instantaneous
so system 1 is that blank moment it is
the ability for the brain to
instantaneously recognize a pattern and
in this book blink Malcolm Gladwell
talks about how out of the corner of
their eyes
pilots can wreck
ize a fighter pilot can recognize
something that might be harmful it
happens near instantaneously from
experience now system two how many know
the answer to this it's not a blink
moment so you have to use that front of
your brain there to start thinking about
it and analyze it and who knows the
differential diagnosis to this it's not
a blink moment right you have to start
thinking about it's that system too as
well so our brains are shifting between
pattern recognition system war on and
thinking system - what do you think the
brain prefers what do you think we're
really designed to do system water
system - the brain really in Thinking
Fast and Slow he lays out the case for
dr. continent of why we prefer system
one system two uses a lot of glucose you
you're gonna go when you're studying for
an exam you go to that refrigerator a
lot because you're burning a lot of
glucose system one is a lot more
efficient for the body and there's great
explanations in this book Thinking Fast
and Slow for why the brain prefer system
one and so this book has really been the
basis for this work in this field of
diagnostic errors where he lays out all
the different types of cognitive
mistakes and dr. Krauss Kerry who's
speaking tomorrow who's an emergency
physician and psychologist has written
many papers on the definitions of all
the different types of cognitive
mistakes we make as clinicians and I'm
sure some of you have heard of premature
closure like coming to an immediate
conclusion and not building out that
differential diagnosis or anchoring you
know having a diagnosis maybe from
another physician and not moving off
that diagnosis to step back and
reconsider the diagnosis overconfidence
etc there's about 30 of these I'm really
interested in this
cognitive mistake called representative
bias so this is the idea that there's a
lot of variant presentations so if I
said the patients in the emergency room
they come in they have crushing chest
pain they have pain down the left arm
they're sweating and they're fatigued
anybody that watches television knows
the think of a myocardial infarction
that's not difficult right but the
patient that comes in to the ER who's 70
years old and says I got the bad
toothache right and gets triage to the
non acute side and doesn't get diagnosed
with that am i that atypical
presentation of the mi is what's causing
a lot more harm than missing super rare
diseases so one of the themes I'll keep
coming back to is that variation of the
common causes a lot more harm than
missing really rare diseases and so we
created an infographic so this is 20
patients in a day and that research from
the National Academy of Sciences are
saying probably to are going to be wrong
and so on the left it says a patient and
red presented with headache diagnosed
tension headache did not realize
workplace exposure to carbon monoxide so
the doctor asked some questions and
course didn't say the patient well where
do you work
patient works in a warehouse they have
propane forklifts that aren't tuned
correctly the patient's breathing carbon
monoxide and gets headache you'd have to
know to ask those questions if you're
the doc but in a fee-for-service system
where we're seeing 20 30 40 patients a
day right you the question is can you
really bring all the knowledge to bear
to that decision-making moment when that
patients in front of you and so the
other one says dizziness diagnosed
benign positional vertigo miss
cerebellar stroke and it was an
anchoring error so there's these
different reasons and you can easily
imagine in this really fast-paced
environment of medical practice and
the USA Today and in your emergency
departments how difficult it is if
you're an emergency position there's
probably 500 different chief complaints
that you're trying to evaluate as an
emergency physician and you have to
shift between you know an orthopedic
injury the chest pain a motor vehicle
accident too rash the dizziness and do
that just out of your brain right so the
question is what are the tools that can
help that brain so another example of
diagnostic error that's been a focus of
my research is this problem so this is a
patient that had three hospital
admissions and six months for this rash
on the legs and you see the the pen
lines that the emergency physician has
drawn around the redness on the legs and
they usually do that because they're
concerned about the extension of an
infection and they're looking to see if
the infection is ascending as in
cellulitis so these were three
admissions for the wrong diagnosis and
research that we did in Rochester fooled
with data from Harbor UCLA showed that
28% of 145 and consecutive admissions
were misdiagnosed in the UK of 635 cases
33% were misdiagnosed and so there are
over a half a million admissions for
cellulitis in the United States each
year and if you get it wrong you're
admitting these patients they get IV
antibiotics and you're giving them
unnecessary lab or during unnecessary
lab tests they're in the hospital often
for days and you're putting them at risk
for C difficile infection or mersa or a
drug reaction when you do the math if
you assume that you can reduce the error
rate from down to you know that from you
need 10% probably false positive you're
not never going to get rid of
all the error but if you assume that you
can improve it by 20% of the errors you
have over a hundred thousand errors
admissions that are unnecessary which is
over a billion dollars in the u.s. each
year spent on people being in the
hospital for cellulitis when they do not
have cellulitis so it's an example
usually a premature closure the red leg
is immediately assumed to be infected
rather than considering other
possibilities so how did we get here so
here we are in 2018 and we have these
problems in healthcare that are very
large and we think about where this
started so this is a copy of a medical
record from the 60s and you know it's
illegible right but that's not really
the main problem at being illegible dr.
weed who's heard of dr. wean here
quite a few great so dr. weed is the
doctor that came up with the idea of the
prom oriented record and soap notes and
what he was saying about this record
wasn't so much that you can't read it
which no one could but that it was
disorganized that there was no common
format in healthcare in medicine for
charting a patient note so you could go
into one doctor's office and it would
say the date mr. Jones and then it would
say pneumonia and they would say
penicillin and 250 milligrams qid times
10 days and that was the entire note and
you go to another doctor's office and it
was a different style to a note so he
came along and said these unstructured
notes are reflection of poor thinking he
says we need to bring consistency to
thinking so this idea of soap brought
forward this idea that you need to take
a very thorough history and get the
subjective you need to do an incredibly
thorough physical exam and gather other
objective data you need to do your
assessment and think through the
possibilities and then create your plan
and when you have that problem list in
the problem list if you don't have a
basis for why you're calling the symptom
of you know trouble trouble swallowing
you know hiatal hernia if you don't put
hiatal hernia the diagnosis in the chart
until you have a basis for the diagnosis
so those many of you work in the
hospital you work with epic here right
and so do you maintain your problem less
well is that is that a problem here the
unmaintained problem will since the
Medical Informatics everybody's talking
about how we can't keep the problem list
up to date but one of the things I've
noticed about the problem was the
problem list has really gone backwards
to becoming a past medical history list
and so doctor we'd said a problem is a
problem until you have a basis for a
diagnosis and and when I look in our
ethnic records at strong Hospital I
never see in the promis unexplained
vomiting or unexplained headache an
actual symptom problem what you see
usually is just a list of diagnoses
which means that all our clinicians are
great diagnosticians because the prom
list just has diagnoses but dr. weed was
saying you keep that as a symptom a
chief complaint until you have a basis
for the diagnosis and if you don't
manage it that way you're encouraging
anchoring you're encouraging people to
pass along the myth of the diagnosis so
he railed against this idea that we
could move information from books and
journals through the brain and be
accurate that that was something that he
he spent his entire career railing
against and for those that never heard
him speak there's this wonderful 1971
internal medicine Grand Rounds at Emory
that we put up on YouTube on the web and
if you disagree we'll Larry we'd
and every YouTube you'll find it it's
really a wonderful talk that he gave in
1971 and still valid today so let's see
if we can get this thing to work
what'd she do now what I'm saying is
that a doctor has to be a guidance
system he is not an Oracle that knows
answer me and once he accepts the
concept of being a guidance system then
he knows that the data system is the
basis from which all is working to take
place and good medicine is a careful
rigorous engineer way towards a more and
more secure position a final diagnosis
is a myth maybe there's something wrong
with whatever running the whole
operation memorize regurgitate forget
memorize regurgitating forget there's
five hundred thousand deaths a year for
mistakes and medicine where's the
outrage so in the 70s doctor we'd
computerized the floor of the Fletcher
Allen Hospital in Burlington Vermont and
so I guess many in the room weren't born
then but anyhow these computers were
these basically like green screens that
had up and down arrows there's no
there's no windows there's no mouse you
just had up and down arrows and a
keyboard and they were all terminals
that would go to a mainframe and the
mainframe would have a probably a room
about half the size that was 50
megabytes of storage or something like
that so think about this and by the way
you could smoke a cigar as you were
working back then in informatics if
you're informatics listen even had your
stogie I guess so anyhow today we're
working on computerizing a floor of a
hospital 1970s so it didn't go well you
know it's still hard to get doctors to
use an EHR but you can imagine in the
early 70s requiring order
to read through a computer and how slow
that was and there's dr. we'd working in
the promise lab he had tens of millions
of dollars of federal grants to develop
this it's just way ahead of his time and
then so by the 80s we had several of
these diagnostic support systems evolved
and the students here probably won't
spend them a day on this verse some some
learning on on these systems internist
one by Jack Myers out of Pittsburgh that
became quick medical reference an Illiad
out of Homer Warner and Utah and be
explained from the MGH lab he explained
is still available you could play around
with that I think on the web you can
find the explain and pkc is what Larry
we'd invented prom knowledge couplers
which is no longer available and this is
a screenshot of the explain so you enter
symptoms in the center and you get
common diagnosis on the right and down
below rare diseases and you can refine
it by it asks you more questions so the
question is after you know thirty years
history of creating diagnostic support
what do most physicians use today and
I'll tell you this is what most
physicians use they just expediently go
to google and they search some symptoms
in google so the question I asked you is
when you get on this plane if your pilot
only had Google to navigate I don't
think anyone that's room will get on
this plane so pilots have instruments
and the instruments are developed and
designed for the task of taxing takeoff
flight landing and taxing those
instruments have a purpose they've been
designed for Google has one algorithm
everything goes through the same
algorithm at Google and it really hasn't
been developed for putting symptoms in
and
a differential so we've been thinking
about at our company this idea of like
what what is the ideal cockpit for
clinicians and our mantra is that it
takes the number of ingredients and real
purpose in the development and so we've
been working for years on a standard
base medical terminology so we have a
relational database mapping terms and
concepts in our database the sno-med for
diagnosis and findings and rxnorm for
medications and we use that terminology
to build a knowledge base and so we're
building a findings to diagnosis
knowledge base where we're using the
medical literature to build this
foundation based on for instance if you
travel to Kuwait
what infectious diseases are you at risk
for so we actually have medical
librarians that are reading w-h-o and
CDC reports on where infectious disease
is moving around the globe and we put
this in a database we've done the same
thing for probably 15 years with case
reports on medication adverse events so
we're not just relying on the initial
trials for the medications but we're
using post release of the drug looking
at all the case reports in PubMed so you
have the standard terminology you
develop a knowledge base and then you
start acquiring images and so it's our
belief that we that pattern recognition
piece of system 1 is a very important
part of problem solving and we need to
enable that that we just can't give
lists of words we have to think about
visualization of data and so we we put
this all together we've merged this
terminology images this knowledge
database and more recently machine
learning on the images that to deliver
answers at the point of care
and so this is a graphic of the typical
kind of result that you would see in a
diagnostic support system like I showed
you and II explained and others would
give you a list and if you didn't know
what a disease is you'd have to click it
and go read it and hold it in your brain
go back to the differential read about
another diagnosis and hold it in your
brain so our approach is visual and
beyond the pictures of rashes you'll see
some diagnostic imaging and then you see
these diagrams so we've created this
idea of the symptom icon which we call
the symptom and the sim to con here is
it's probably hard to see in the back of
the room but it says cubital tunnel
syndrome now if I give you a page of
text on cubital tunnel syndrome would be
hard to immediately know from that page
of text where is it
where's the distribution what are the
symptoms and so the goal of the symptoms
is to put into an interface the ability
to see the key findings of the diagnosis
so that when you have a differential you
can compare between the symptom patterns
and so this is a graphic of two
different searches of the same disease
and this ties into the assertion that
variation of the comment causes more
harm than missing rare diseases so in
this side there's been an entry of
facial palsy and our thrashes and it
finds at the top of the image stack lyme
disease in this other search someone
searched trash and target lesion and
because rash was entered the system knew
to put a picture on the top so the idea
is that lyme disease can present many
different ways some people say they
never saw a rash some people didn't know
they had a rash it was on their backside
it came and went six months later they
present with facial droop arthralgias or
they present years
later with neuropathy from more advanced
Lyme disease
so Lyme disease can present many many
different ways and so what we've done is
we in this interface we've stacked all
these pictures and diagrams that show
different phases and depending on which
findings you enter that it flips these
pictures around as it builds the
differential another feature or what
we're doing related to variation is
there's been bias and knowledge in
medicine and so the books back when
people use those things called books
we're really skewed towards Atlas is of
disease and people with light skin so
since the beginning of our company we've
been very purposeful the same we want to
represent disease and people of all
colors so in our interface you can click
on the right and choose between the
fitzpatrick skin type one through sex
and then it will flip you and show you
the rash presentations and people or
color or just light skin however you
want to present it and there's another
shot of the synth akan from an
informatics point of view the greatest
challenge for us is not the technology
it's building awareness that this tool
is available and getting doctors who use
it and so the system is now in 2300
hospitals and large clinics and there
are over 90 academic centers and have it
and teach with it to some degree and I
say to some degree because there's also
variability not just in clinical
variability there's variability in how
we're teaching about tools and how we're
using tools and so this is really a
cultural problem more than it is a
technical problem and so it's our belief
we have to get into as many workflows as
possible so that the clinicians will
start to take advantage of the
information so visual DX can integrate
into the EHR using either the
hl7 infobutton standard or the smart and
fire standards that are now evolving and
it also is used on a smartphone with
Android or iPhone you can use it on
either device and we can we integrate it
as well into up to date so you can be
searching and up to date and see a
visual the X result in the search
results of up to date so we work very
very hard to get visual DX visible but
still medicine is has one foot in that
twentieth century of memorization and
the other foot into something future
aspiration of using evidence and we are
all living through this transition from
this memory based paradigm to a digital
paradigm in an evidence based paradigm
and so that really is we can talk it
more about it during questions and
answers but it's certainly a challenge
for us so here's a screenshot of epoch
and this is our quality and safety use
case of your clinical question is is the
medication causing the problem and so
what we've done is we've engineered it
so you can right click on the Med and it
will send a mad code up to the cloud to
our server and then we'll send back to
epoch the drug reaction differential
it's inside epic I do not know if this
is turned on at o Hsu it takes about 30
minutes to be configured it's ethnics
using the standard we're using the
standard but I just don't know we'll
have to look into it to see if it's
turned on here anyone know
now there's a real informatics issue
here this is a really great sub story to
this this is using what's called the hl7
infobutton standard well epic took the
info button out of the standard you have
to know that you can right click on a
value like a problem and the problem or
met in the Med list and then you run the
search called active guidelines now in
our institution we've had this turned on
for six years and I'm still showing it
to people ago when did you add that you
know six years ago
so here's a problem of design where epic
and it's infinite wisdom took the input
button out of the info button standard
the info buttons the little iconic eye
that would sit next to a value that you
would know that's a signal that you can
operate on that value to get additional
information so it's no surprise that
most people don't know most doctors
don't know that they can right click to
use clinical decision support right in
the record and here's a screenshot from
Cerner using the hl7 smart on fire
standard went one step further where we
can pull from Cerner and we'll be doing
this with epic soon the began in stop
dates of medications and one of the
challenges in the hospital where you
have a patient that's on ten medications
and your clinical question is which man
might be causing this problem as you
want to recognize when meds were started
and stopped to see the temporal
relationship between the medication and
the new symptom and so we can pull the
start and stop dates and then represent
graphically with a timeline when meds
were started and stopped and the same
thing the drug reactions inside of
Cerner so I want to segue into machine
learning everybody's probably heard
about machine
in the room is that a fair assumption so
there's a tremendous amount of news on
machine learning there's it's certainly
a tsunami of activity of interest and
research and progress that's advancing
way faster than most people thought it
would advance and particularly around
the imaging specialty so radiology
dermatology ophthalmology you just keep
seeing these press releases there's just
an a machine-learning approval by the
FDA for diabetic retinopathy and there's
really some compelling research there's
also a lot of hype it sounds like you
know that doctors won't exist in five
years based on some of these news
reports so here's a picture of a
pediatrician in Rochester taking a
picture of a child with our machine
learning app feature of our app and
here's a photo of dr. Brown dr. Brown is
the chair of emergency medicine at the
University of Maryland in Baltimore and
this was really a great example I'm
hoping I can get my iPhone up to show
this to you and in real-time so this
patient came in to the IDI and told the
resident that she had a lesion on her
finger two weeks earlier that was
hanging by a stalk so the patient tied a
string around it and ripped it off and
she's told the doctor that it bled like
crazy and then it came back that much
larger so this is when she shows up in
the ER it's now larger than where she
started two weeks earlier the resident
didn't know what it is and then dr.
Brown came in and he didn't know what it
was but we had licensed visual DX
University of Maryland so I got this new
app so he takes a picture of of it I'll
see if I can recreate this because he
sent me the photo
all right so what he did was he turned
on the camera in the app and he took a
picture and here's the picture stored in
my camera roll and then he clicked use
this photo and it says analyzing photo
there we go so on the bottom there's
three icons the left says fry up friable
papule the center one says skin ulcer
the third on the rights of skin erosion
so he's looking at these he says yeah I
think that's a friable pap you'll all
agree with that so he clicks that he hit
to continue and then he types in finger
and then he hit new results and it gave
him a different Rancho with these little
pictures so he's looking carefully at
these pictures and he sees the second
one dance a finger with something looks
really bloody so he got curious about
that the resident was standing behind
him and he was doing this in the exam
room with the patient watching him do
this and so he clicked the picture and
he started swiping with his finger and
the resident was gone huh and it was and
he told me there was no interchange of
words they were just looking at these
pictures he's just doing this and he got
here I think it was this one he got here
and then he enlarged that he said wow
that really looks similar and then he
went over and read about it where it
said pyogenic granulomas are rapidly
growing and the patient watched them do
this and he said I think this is what
you have I'm not sure we're going to
refer you it says it's benign we'll get
it refer you and then he texted the
image to the dermatologist who responded
the next day and said hey dr. Brown
impressive I didn't think you'd nail
that one so this is a great example of
pushing skills down to generalist so if
we go in and we say sorry about getting
text here
let's do one more so if we we say take
this lesion and the ear and say use this
photo
it says cutaneous horn thick scaly
papule callus so there's 80 different
skin exam morphologies that we've
trained the machine learning to so what
it's doing is not going directly to the
diagnosis we're asking the user to
confirm whether they think that's what
the lesion type is and what we're really
interested in studying and this would be
a great project for the fella is this
idea of machine learning to enhance
skills not to descale there's been a
quite a bit of conversation in the last
five years in general about AI in
society Dease killing people there's
been some studies of pilots wear this
thing pilots are using the autopilot so
much that they're using some of that
tactile learn skills that the older
pilots have and you know there's thought
that people that if we had self-driving
cars all the time that people wouldn't
have the skills that they really need to
drive and snow or whatever so with this
model what we're doing is we're
presenting the rich vocabulary of
Dermatology to the non dermatologist and
this is a real key to accurate
dermatological is you have to categorize
that physical exam well so if you can
look at a patient and and resident our
student says doctor appear they're a
group than billa cated vesicles I
already know they're thinking about our
Petach infection so you have to do
better than saying it's a rash or it's a
lesion on the finger so we're very very
interested in can we use machine
learning to prompt the physical exam
terminology and we'll primary care
doctors and ER doctors start to do
better and learn this terminology so
that's the professional app and I'll
just while I have it up I'll just
quickly show you
it's not just machine learning like you
could go in and say let's pretend we'll
pretend that the patient here who had
this lesion on the finger and we use it
so you've analyzed someone's lesion this
time we'll do an ulcer and we go ahead
and we say ulcer in a traveler to Kuwait
so I put in the patient went to Kuwait
and now I hit view results and it's
showing me brucellosis old world
cutaneous leishmaniasis and cutaneous
amebiasis so this is an example of
bringing together that knowledge base
with the machine learning so we don't
think machine learning is going to get
you to diagnosis because there are a lot
of other factors that we leverage in
diagnosis beyond the image you know in
dermatology there certainly there are
those system one blank moments that
that's Malcolm Gladwell's describing
where the patient comes in and
dermatologists need no history they just
say that's a basal cell or that's
psoriasis right and the patient that
comes in say with pink spots all over
their body and I have no history I don't
know if that's a drug reaction I don't
know if they travel then they have
chikungunya virus from traveling to
Central America
I wouldn't know until I ask some
questions so part of our strategy is to
put machine learning together with this
knowledge base to deliver better answers
at the point of care now the other part
of machine learning that we're working
on that we're really excited about is a
new app that you all can download it's
free right now called ASA and then go
back to the beginning and hold on start
so ASA we've been working on this for
over a year thinking about how can we
deliver to people on their smartphone
they be the ability to triage themselves
better than going to say Google or WebMD
and so the idea let me start right from
the beginning and start the app so you
download the app for free from the app
store it says what is a SAG ID to help
you answer questions about common skin
conditions
well ASA covers over 200 conditions
there's only a small part of medicine
ASA doesn't diagnose only trained
practitioners can do that
when in doubt have your health care
provider check it out and so you
understand and then it says start a new
case and you turn it on and you take a
picture all right so I'm selecting this
picture now this picture was given to me
by our product manager for ASA so our
product manager for ASA was at a wedding
about three weeks ago he sees his cousin
this cousin says them Joe I hear you
took a job with a dermatology company I
have a rash she puts out her hand at the
wedding and he says I have this app yeah
so I do work for dermatology garden so
he takes this picture and he hits use
this photo and now it says it doesn't
say medical terms like friable papule it
asks in lay terms is this a flat smooth
area of skin larger than your thumbnail
that's darker than normal skin tone and
he said yes and then he set up a profile
for her or were you put in female I'm
not going to do that now let's say it
was on me and you have to decide whether
it's a single little focal lesion it's a
rash somewhere or it's all over the body
so he chose the middle one and then it
asked you where is it and he select it
was on the back of the hand and then he
hit continue and it asked how long have
you had the condition
and he said she had it days a week and
then says does it itch he said no do you
have a fever
no and then it tallies up all the
responses and then you hit show results
and it shows a bunch of different
matches to the scenario you put in so
he's looking at this she's looking over
his shoulder and the second one Dan said
Lyme rash so he clicks that and he
starts swiping through with her looking
at the pictures now this is all system
one right this is all just pattern
recognition there they're not doctors
right and he's swiping through and they
get to this picture which you all can
see look similar to the original picture
where we started and then he reads that
people are exposed to the combination of
lime juice and the sunlight get this
rash it's called bartenders dermatitis
it's also called phyto photo dermatitis
for Lyme rash as a late-term so this is
an incredible story because his cousin
saw a healthcare provider that got it
wrong and he turned to her and said even
you know you've been cutting limes and
says you know how did you know and
they're both not physicians so and you
know it's really a cool story because
this is a harmless kind of rash I mean
you're not gonna die from this rash
right and you have people that are angry
at doctors for making them wait an hour
in the waiting room to pay a $40 copay
to get there and get the wrong answer to
get a diagnostic error and so we're at
this inflection point in our society
where doctors because of fee-for-service
medicine and because how complex
medicine is it seems it's a high volume
of patients you cannot expect a family
physician to know all of medicine we
can't expect an ER doctor to perform
flawlessly but I think the patient's
expect that and if they especially if
they wait an extra hour in the waiting
room so let me just wrap it up
now this was from an entrepreneurial
point of view I'll thump my chest small
companies love this kind of attention so
Tim Cook at Apple during the quarterly
Apple investor call last November held
this up as an example of machine
learning on the iPhone and the reason he
did was Apple announced last year this
technique called core ml and so what
core ml allows you to do is support your
machine learning algorithm on to the
iPhone and process the image on the
iPhone so when we do those analysis when
I did the picture from dr. Brown and you
saw that progress bar that progress bar
is actually a dummy progress bar it's
not real an iPhone 7 or newer analyzes
that image in under one tenth of a
second and when we first released the
machine learning the users didn't
realize that machine learning can happen
so the designer put in this dummy
progress bar that said analyzing image
so as people thought was broken they
didn't think anything happened so this
is really incredible because to train
the machine learning they have these
really fast computers they have it
digest a hundred thousand images it
takes like two days to create the
machine learning model it packages it up
into a hundred megabyte file they put it
on the iPhone with this Cornell and then
it runs it in less than 1/10 of a second
it's really pretty amazing that you can
do that on a on a smartphone take a
picture and I think this is going to
transform not just medicine but you know
I think already there are all these
consumer apps around identifying plants
and leaves and birds where you can do
this but the medical informatics piece
of core ml is it's great for privacy so
what it did for us it ensures our
clients that we don't have any HIPAA
information we have no pictures of
patients in our server from our
professional app
so image gets analyzed and then the
image gets dumped never goes up to the
cloud we're able to tell our clients
don't worry we don't have pictures of
patients faces because we don't have any
pictures of any of your patients it's
happened all on the iPhone and so
patients are change agents and that's a
really important part of what we try to
do we really try to teach physicians
about using technology to engage the
patient the patient's are all on the
internet before they visit with us or on
Google they're on WebMD and a doctor
looking up information in a database
actually communicates to the patient hey
she cared enough to look it up in front
of me
and to show me that she didn't just wing
it
that she actually dug a little deeper so
we spent a lot of time trying to educate
to this idea of doing it using these
tools with patients and so this is just
a slide about terminology so sitting
under the hood of both visual DX and ASA
is a technical platform for the
knowledge base and the terminology so on
the left it says
consumer common search terms aching
joints heart racing small bumps on skin
and on the right it says arthralgia
tachycardia tiny papule and so there's a
concept oriented relational database
that we've developed matching the
sno-med we have consumer terms we have
professional terms we've translated the
interface and search terms and diagnosis
names in visual DX to Spanish the French
to German Mandarin in a few months
Japanese and Portuguese and if you
develop with a relational database and
you have a concept oriented build then
you can do all that and then you can
scale it right so foundational you have
to set the right foundation and your
informatics
and I'm sure that's part of the teaching
here and I think that's part of our
ability to move forward with ASA as
quickly we as we did is all part of the
same development platform and so I think
the AI and the clinician plus the
patient will result in these benefits
and it's your generation that's going to
fix all these problems that we have in
healthcare so thank you and if for those
of you who want to leave need to leave
I'll feel free to do so and then dr.
papay is gonna stick around and everyone
else is welcome to and we can ask them
questions about this we can ask them
anything we want but let me go ahead and
turn the actually can you turn the
lights up